on this Monday night concerns about
patient confidentiality complaints the
University of Toronto collected
thousands of medical records without
consent of course we value research but
it can't be at the risk of privacy a
global news exclusive the hero in an
horrific Massacre I realized I needed to
get the weapon away from him the young
man who confronted the gunman in
Monterey Park California new controversy
over how the arrive can app was
developed highly illogical and
inefficient and she is a putt Above the
Rest how Canadian golfing champ Brooke
Henderson has sliced her way into
history
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with allegations of a data
breach involving the privacy of medical
records in Ontario a group of doctors
has filed a complaint about a massive
data project they believe broke
provincial privacy laws and violated
patient trust the doctors who have
shared their complaint with global news
alleged the research project at the
University of Toronto collected and
shared over 600 000 electronic medical
records without the consent or knowledge
of patients privacy experts say the case
centers on finding a balance between
better Public Health Data and protecting
patients rights Karen Lieberman has our
top story tonight
most people Expect When you visit your
doctor that your personal health
information is kept confidential medical
data is so sensitive Global News has
learned Ontario's privacy commissioner
is investigating a complaint filed by a
group of Toronto area doctors that
alleges more than 600 000 electronic
medical records have been collected
without patient consent patients were
not afforded any real opportunity to
withdraw they were completely unaware
the doctors allege the University of
Toronto practice-based research Network
or utopian has collected medical records
from 1400 family physicians in a massive
data grab that violates privacy laws
there must be some ability to identify
people from the de-identified data
otherwise why would they care so they're
saying
look of course we value research but it
can't be at the risk of privacy patient
credit card information is also
allegedly being collected the data is
sent to utopian servers where it is
de-identified stripped of some direct
identifiers like names and according to
the complaint sold to researchers an
allegation denied by the University of
Toronto for personal health information
if all that's been removed are very
direct identifiers to me that's not
anonymized Health Data privacy and
health experts say the complaint
highlights a growing debate about
balancing the need for better Public
Health Data with protecting patients
privacy rights we need big data when I
say big data I mean we need large
Healthcare data sets we all know that we
really learned it powerfully in the
pandemic but you know what most
Canadians are okay with that but they
need to know what is going on Utopia now
feeds into an even larger data sharing
project with other participating
universities and has collected 1.8
million electronic medical records that
could become a prime target for
ransomware attacks says this cyber
security expert our Healthcare networks
as well as our research environments are
Mainline targets for many of our
adversaries including China and Russia
utopian declined an interview with
global news after we sent a list of
questions which went unanswered its
website was updated indicating it was
pausing any collection use or transfer
of data the university did tell us by
email that it is working with the
Privacy commissioner to address the
concerns in the complaint adding that
patient data is stored on servers at a
high security facility only accessed by
authorized Personnel Donna Karen
Lieberman in Toronto thank you Alberta
is farming out more surgeries to private
clinics to help relieve patient backlogs
a clinic called Canadian surgery
Solutions will receive Public Funding to
perform 3 000 hip and knee replacement
surgeries for patients within Alberta's
Health System it's not a first for the
province and while the government says
the move is necessary to reduce wait
times critics worry the Outsourcing of
surgery to private clinics will
ultimately cost everyone more Heather
urich's West explains
the painful weight for hip or knee
surgery can take years thousands of
Canadians are caught in surgical
backlogs particularly for elective
Orthopedic surgeries the weights have
existed within Canada's health system at
the best of times but they've been made
much worse by covet 19. the wait times
are far too long and we have to get them
down to do that Alberta is looking at
private surgical facilities Contracting
3 000 hip and knee replacement
procedures from Canadian Surgical
Solutions those surgeries are in
addition to surgeries done in hospitals
this contract will increase total
Orthopedic surgeries in Calgary by 21
percent the procedures remain publicly
funded patients don't pay out of pocket
and they won't jump the queue it's also
not new to Alberta last spring the
government boosted its number of private
contracts for cataract surgeries since
then it says the wait list has been
nearly cut in half this is going to be
safe uh it's going to be regulated
Alberta's announcement comes less than a
week after Ontario unveiled a similar
plan with a focus first on Contracting
out thousands of cataract surgeries
before expanding to hip and knee
procedures as well but critics say the
privatization plan is flawed private
companies exist to make a profit and
every Healthcare dollar that goes to
companies profit margin is a dollar that
is taken out of the public system
instead Alberta's NDP says the
government should focus on expanding the
province's public health system with
tens of thousands of patients waiting
right across the country one thing is
clear something needs to be done
additionally albertans were left waiting
after a network outage took down a
number of the province's computer
systems including net care and connect
Care Systems that hospitals rely on to
treat patients Emergency Services was
also impacted though 9-1-1 Services
remained functional a number of elective
surgeries however did have to be
canceled Donna all right Heather York's
West in Calgary thank you in
Newfoundland and Labrador the government
wants to end a strike by private
ambulance workers it has proposed new
legislation that would make ambulances
essential Premier Andrew Fury called an
emergency debate today if passed the
legislation would ensure Services
continue in the event of a striker
lockout about 100 workers are on strike
right now over wages and pensions and
much of the island of Newfoundland is
served by private ambulances Health Care
is on the minds of millions of Canadians
as a federal cabinet Retreat begins in
Ontario prime minister Justin Trudeau
and his ministers are gathering for
three days to set the priorities ahead
of parliament's return next week long
wait times for Medical Care Plus Rising
interest rates the cost of living and a
potential recession are all Hot Topics
turia Israeli is in Hamilton where the
retreat is taking place Toria
Donna the ministers are back from the
holidays and laying out their priorities
for the next session of Parliament and
chief among them will be Canada's
struggling Health Care system that will
likely dominate the conversation over
the next three days straight to be in
Hamilton lots of work to do thank you
prime minister Justin Trudeau repeated
that he is optimistic the federal
government will reach deal with the
provinces I know Canadians need us to
come together to solve health care for
the medium and long term and that's
exactly what we're working on with uh
with Canadian with uh with premiers
right now we're going to continue to
work collaboratively on the things that
Canadians expect us to do conservative
leader Pierre polyev was less optimistic
idealism in it Trudeau has delivered
nothing on health care for eight years
our health care is worse than ever after
nearly a decade of Trudeau why because
he spent all of his time fighting with
the premiers the other big issue on the
table this week is the rising cost of
living inflation is slowing down and
unemployment remains low but another
interest rate hike is likely on the
horizon the Bank of Canada is expected
to announce its eighth hike in a row on
Wednesday with most forecasting an
increase of a quarter percentage point
the minister say they're here to come up
with a plan on how to make life more
affordable and they're hoping it
resonates across the country and
especially here in Hamilton this is
traditionally an NDP stronghold but the
Liberals made gains in the last election
this Retreat will set the road map for
the return to Parliament it will also
offer clues for what we can expect in
the budget which will likely be tabled
in the spring Donna teria Israel and
Hamilton Ontario the Prime Minister had
some blunt words about how the federal
arrived can app was created The Globe
and Mail first reported an Ottawa I.T
firm which the government hired to build
the app for 44 million dollars actually
subcontracted the work to other
companies
obviously this is a practice that seems
highly illogical and inefficient and I
have made sure that the clerk of the
privy council is looking into
procurement practices to make sure that
we're getting value for money and that
we're doing things in a smart and
logical way arrivecan was created to
screen incoming Travelers and track
their vaccination status and was fraught
with glitches according to documents
seen by global news and Ottawa I.T firm
GC strategies was hired by the
government for the project it contracted
out the work to six other companies and
employees were paid a daily rate of
twelve hundred dollars or more GC
strategies confirmed it build the
federal government nine million dollars
over two years early estimates put the
cost of the arrive can app at eighty
thousand dollars but that soared to over
54 million in the end
Alberta's Justice Ministry says it has
found no evidence of email contact
between staff in the office of Alberta's
Premier and the Alberta Crown
prosecution service in a statement that
Justice Ministry says it has undertaken
what it calls a comprehensive review of
emails sent over a four-month period CBC
News reported last week a premier's
office staffer sent a series of emails
to Crown prosecutors challenging their
assessment and Direction on court cases
connected to last year's Coots border
blockade and protests CBC news says it
has not seen the emails the Justice
Ministry says no further review will be
conducted unless more evidence is
brought forward
in Washington four more members of The
Oath Keepers have been found guilty of
seditious conspiracy for their
involvement in the 2021 attack on the
U.S Capitol the members of the far-right
militia group were accused of trying to
keep former president Donald Trump in
power after his defeat in November a
separate jury convicted the group's
leader in connection with the attack
which delayed the certification of
President Joe Biden's victory
in California the 72 year old suspect in
a weekend mass shooting has been found
dead and a young man is being hailed as
a hero for disarming him an 11th person
has now died after that gunman opened
fire inside a dance studio in Monterey
Park near Los Angeles tonight survivors
are recounting the horror that unfolded
and how one man wrestled the gun away
from the suspect when he turned up at a
second dance studio Jackson prosco
reports
these are the moments that may have
prevented a second Massacre my first
thoughts was I was going to die here
this was it security video obtained by
ABC news shows bystander Brandon say
wrestling with a gunman just minutes
after a mass shooting at a nearby dance
studio something came over me I realized
I needed to get the weapon away from him
I needed to take this weapon disarm him
or else everybody would have died
it was at that first location where a
night of Celebration turned to horror
late Saturday
Hattie Peng was inside the Lunar New
Year party when shots rang out you will
see the body already several lying there
after the first shooting it's believed
the gunman traveled to the second
location where he was beaten back and
ultimately fled the suspect 72 year old
who can Tran was later found dead of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound he was
reportedly a one-time regular at the
dance studio where he met his ex-wife a
motive remains unclear in the aftermath
one of the largest Asian communities in
the U.S is reeling as people search for
missing friends and loved ones I tried
to reach them I didn't get an answer the
senselessness of it all has shaken the
community already on edge from a rise in
anti-asian hate crimes I feel this sense
of great loss about the home that I
always had it's just it's just gone I'll
never be able to feel safe here again in
a nation where there are more guns Than
People a sense of exasperation and
exhaustion has quickly set in why do we
have so many guns in this country and
even more on the horizon
it's not right other countries don't
operate this way and we should not
either but in Monterey Park this is not
just another mass shooting it is an
unspeakable tragedy that has shattered a
community
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
in Ukraine more emergency power Cuts
were ordered today because Russian
strikes have damaged the power grid and
the EU has agreed to another 726 million
dollars in military aid EU foreign
ministers approved the package along
with another 60 million for non-lethal
equipment they were meeting in Brussels
after the West failed last week to agree
on sending german-made leopard two tanks
to Ukraine President zielinski says a
supply of Western Battle Tanks is badly
needed Germany now says it will not
stand in the way if Poland decides to
send them
new turbulence for sun wing customers
coming up the latest provinces facing
canceled flights
there is more turmoil in the Canadian
airline industry this time sun wing is
canceling winter getaway flights from
the maritimes to Southern destinations
Ross Lord explains why and who is
affected
even since pandemic restrictions were
lifted finding a steady rhythm in the
Canadian airline industry is impossible
for example the toronto-based airline
sun wing widely condemned for leaving
passengers stranded for days over the
Christmas holidays sun wing is now
scaling back earlier this month it
canceled flight south from Regina
Saskatoon and from Winnipeg now it's
scrapping weekly flights from Halifax to
Orlando Florida and to KO Largo Del
suracuba flights from Moncton and
Fredericton New Brunswick are also being
reduced or canceled
among those left in the Lurch are
Lindsay May and her fiance they've been
thwarted for a second time in their plan
to fly sun wing from Regina to Mexico
for their wedding why did you let us
rebook and then take back that promise
it's just become totally absurd at this
point sunwing's recent woe started with
a plan to bring in pilots from Europe we
had a certain amount of assurances from
our our legal team that this should be a
successful application and we proceeded
down that road when the federal
government rejected the foreign Pilot's
sun wing was stuck they're trying to
figure out okay what should this Airline
look like given the fact we've got 64
fewer Pilots than we had originally
planned and that's what you're seeing
with these cancellations John gratick
suggests the winner could be WestJet
which is planning a takeover I would
suggest to say that the value of the sun
wing brand has been affected by their
actions over the last month passenger
Advocates say Airlines would be more
responsible if the governor government
regulator doled out stiffer penalties in
the few cases her Airlines were fine at
all for breaking the law it was
something like 200 dollars per passenger
it is not even a slap on the wrist it's
more like a mosquito bite transport
Minister Omar al-gabra says it's up to
sun wing how it manages its schedule as
long as it compensates passengers
properly although some customers say
they're still waiting for compensation
from their holiday ordeal Ross Lord
Global News
Mass layoffs in the tech sector ahead
while once booming sector is shrinking
its Workforce
we are only weeks into 2023 and it's
already been a Grim start for workers in
the tech sector some of the world's
biggest Tech Giants have laid off tens
of thousands of employees it is a
continuation of a trend from the end of
last year and gaviola explains why it's
happening and what you can do if you get
a pink slip
kova 19 lockdowns in 2020 meant big
business for big Tech the increase in
remote work for many plus more screen
time drove a boom in e-commerce spending
but those days are over companies are
realizing that hey we actually want to
cut our costs and take care of our
shareholders and they're pretty much
sacrificing the employees to do that
Tech saw more job Cuts than any other
industry last year layoffs increased 650
percent compared with 2021 that is
according to a top U.S consulting firm
and already 2023 is seeing a steady
stream of mass layoffs too if you're
part of a union it should be your first
connection after getting the news if
you're not unionized don't sign anything
keep all documents showing how long
you've been employed and under what
circumstances then contact an employment
lawyer who can make sure you're getting
what you deserve financially Severance
offers are typically going to be low
a company is going to be banking on
enough people accepting low Severance
offers
um to offset the amount that they're
going to have to pay for those who
actually pursue their Severance packages
I know a lot of people are going through
a tough time but um you have to start
thinking about negotiating your
Severance paying Toby oluwole was laid
off from his Tech job in 2017 and he
wants people who find themselves
suddenly unemployed to know this it's
not your fault
he's now helping people negotiate higher
salaries go back to the drawing board
and start with what fuels me what
actually made me passionate in the first
place this is a great time for career
transitions 2022 was a job Seekers
Market but even though the tides are
turning in 2023 there remains a shortage
of skilled Tech workers meaning many can
likely find employment elsewhere and
gaviola Global News Toronto
Canadian golf's greatest next how Brooke
Henderson etched her name in the record
books
[Music]
Brooke Henderson has made Canadian golf
history the 25 year old from Ontario
claimed her 13th LPGA Tour title
yesterday the most professional wins of
any Canadian golfer it was a dream start
to the 2023 tour season and as Eric
Sorensen reports the elite golfer has
her eye on even more prizes
a brook Henderson Drive it may be the
best part of her golf game long shots
that have made her a top 10 player in
the world but as a new golf season kicks
off Henderson displayed a putting
prowess this weekend that helped her
pull ahead of the world's best players
and never look back she's very powerful
player Ted green she's as good as
anybody in the world and when her
putting is is uh as good as it was last
week she's very difficult to beat as
Henderson tapped in on 18 she was
congratulated as always by her sister
Brittany who's her caddy and the usual
throng of Canadian fans who form Brooks
Brigade at almost every tour stop all
the fans that come out and a lot of
Canadians out here too so it's just an
incredible week and a great way to start
the new year it may seem old hat for
Henderson who wins on tour almost every
year but it's an astonishing achievement
it is Henderson's 13th LPGA Tour Victory
each win a new Canadian record putting
more distance between her and the other
winningest pro golfers in Canadian
history and Henderson is only 25. Brooke
has high expectations of herself and I
think she's she's a great representative
of Canada and we're just cheering her on
and we hope that she continues to play
to play great and makes everybody in
Canada proud in the off season Henderson
was forced to overcome back problems had
wisdom teeth taken out and had to adjust
to entirely new clubs a big change for a
golfer there definitely was a lot of
patience involved especially early on in
the off-season but yeah a lot of big
changes a lot of things but you know I
couldn't have worked out any better
indeed Brooke Henderson is off to the
best start of her career and now leads
the points race to be the best female
golfer in the world World in 2023 Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's year
in Canada is the Winnipeg
discoveriel across the Red River and the
Canadian Museum of Human Rights we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you